hello what glad you've joined us for
this live webinar unraveling the legacy
and future of hepatitis B diagnosis
clinical impacts of conventional
molecular tests and HCV RNA to monitor
hepatic infections i am michelle ashton
of blabbers and i'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lappers the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration it's
presented by Abbott molecular to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.sap.com/learnbi kering the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
drop down box located on the far left of
your screen labeled ask a question and
click on the send button questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the fly window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the ask a
question box on the far left of your
screen this presentation is educational
and best offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located at the top
right of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Gavin
clarity of Abbott Diagnostics to learn
more about our speaker please in the
speaker tab at the top-right of the
presentation window dr. Cole Bertie will
now begin his presentation
thank you and thanks for joining me
start with the disclosure slide let's
leave that up for people to to see if
you have a second disclosure slide that
relates to the assay that we will
mention a little bit more about during
this presentation the HPD RNA Si and
it's a research use a say at this point
it's not for a diagnostic to use
most of you will know hepatitis B is a
significant health problem globally with
an estimated two billion people have
been exposed to hepatitis B and about
300 million people are chronically
infected worldwide as you can see from
this slide there's an uneven
distribution of prevalence of hepatitis
B with the higher prevalence in Asia and
sub-saharan Africa relative to North and
South America and Europe
you
there's been a lot of excitement around
the area of hepatitis viral hepatitis
and particularly around hepatitis C
that's now considered a curable large
securable disease due to the development
of direct-acting antiviral so now a
person who has hepatitis C could be
cured in as little as eight weeks with
one pill once a day so it's it's quite a
fantastic development and why that is
possible for Hep C you can see in this
slide that the virus does not have a
good reservoir in the host is basically
present in the cytoplasm and it doesn't
integrate into the host DNA as you can
see HIV is very different that it has a
integrated gene it becomes basically
part of the person that has infects and
this profile DNA can produce replicating
virus so you've got that lingering
reservoir there that's very difficult to
eradicate hepatitis C does not have that
so treatment for 8 to 12 weeks is
sufficient to stop application allow the
hypothesis to turn over in the patient
be cured hepatitis B again in contrast
is not like hepatitis C or HIV probably
a little more similar to HIV than Hep C
as it does have a reservoir in the
patient pata site in the form of a
covalently closed circular DNA molecule
and little pseudo chromosome that is
remained in the nucleus and as difficult
to eradicate this slide illustrates the
standard HPV lifecycle and the standard
of care today which is a nucleoside
analogs and you can see that the the
virus enters the cell is unwrapped makes
its way to the nucleus where it's
present either as a relaxed circular DNA
molecule or a covalent closed circular
DNA molecule acting in that reservoir of
the virus in the parasite and from there
it makes its RNA intermediaries and
proteins etc etc of the life cycle and
eventually in a
encapsulated virus leaves the cell
what's interesting in this slide is
you'll see the two x's there and that
indicates the part of the viral life
cycle
that's interrupted by the administration
of nucleoside analog so basically the
conversion of the viral RNA into DNA is
stopped but nothing else is really
impacted by nucleoside analog therapy
everything that happens upstream from
the RNAs to the CCC DNA is not impacted
by this treatment and not an alternative
therapy which is also available but as a
very unfavorable side-effect profile as
pegylated interferon and that's not used
a lot in developed countries or a lot
around the world although the treatment
is finite and it does have a lot of side
effects so extended nucleoside analog
treatment is the preferred route and
that can be years decades or even
lifetime of therapy
so stimulated by the great success in
the development of new drugs for
hepatitis C there's a significant amount
of interest and effort being placed into
developing new curative and better
therapies for hepatitis B this is a very
busy slide but it illustrates a lot of
the efforts and the targets for these
new therapies whether they be immune
modulators entry inhibitors capsid
modulators in trying to find different
ways to treat hepatitis B by attacking
different parts of the virus life cycle
also illustrates many of the
pharmaceutical companies that are
actively involved in this effort
the holy grail for these new treatments
would be to either eradicate eliminate
the reservoir of hepatitis B from the
hepatocytes be covalently chose circular
DNA or to render it transcriptionally
file and to turn it off so effectively
turning the engine off and in order to
understand the impact that these drugs
are having on the virus in the nucleus
it's important to have surrogate markers
that are available in the plasma of the
patient's receiving the drugs that would
give us a window into what's happening
in an indication on the effect of these
drugs some black potential biomarkers
that are illustrated here are the pre
genomic RNA which is the first thing
that the covalent closed circular DNA
makes it's a very good target also
hepatitis B II antigen and s antigen
those are areas that are routinely
looked at for new drug development
this graph that was recently published
in Butler's Elle and hepatology
illustrates the dynamic of the viral
kinetics of hepatitis B traditionally
you see the DNA that a relatively high
level drops precipitously once you
decide on treatment is started in
contrast to that hepatitis B RNA as we
showed in the previous slide or
discussed in the previous slide is not
impacted by this therapy so it remains
relatively stable even as the DNA levels
drop then over time of the CCP DNA
becomes less actor for less
transcriptionally active it's a levels
of RNA detectable in the plasma
decreases
facilitate this research Abbott has
developed a HPV RNA si that's highly
automated on the M mm platform we
designed the ad site to be high
throughput and to be reproducible and
precise to have a excellent sensitivity
with the limit of detection at about
forty four units per mil we try to
calibrate our HPD RNA units to the
whu-oh DNA standard to have some frame
of reference we also wanted to compare
this test to the existing manual method
that was used to study HPV RNAs
published in van Bummel Adel and it's a
race meant that that's a rapid
amplification of cDNA ends and that is a
limit of detection of about 300 copies
per mil again manual method quite
labor-intensive in the design of this
assay we also placed two targets one an
X and one in core the rationale for
having two targets in our essay was
twofold one for redundancy in case of a
mutation that might impact the
performance of one of these targets and
secondly to try and understand if the
virus was producing only entire pre
genomic RNA or if there were other
species of RNA that may be present in
the plasma so looking for the one or a
combination of all
shows a small study we did and looking
at the relative performance of the habit
RNAs a compared to the race method and
you can see where in in the right hand
side where both assays were detectable
and quantifiable the correlation was
quite good as excellent at the low end
there was a little bit of a deviation
but I think that probably relates more
to the manual method so the imprecision
around the manual method versus an
automated method and then on the left
hand side you can see that the Abbott
method is considerably more sensitive as
expected in the race method of many of
the samples that were undetectable by
this method we're still detectable and
are quantifiable by the adult RNA assay
we wanted to look at the correlation of
this pre genomic RNA assay in patients
who are chronically treated and on
therapy versus those who were not
treated and to see what the dynamic
would be and how the DNA and RNA values
would relate to each other and you can
see here in panel a and a chronically
effective have be patient who's on
treatment as expected the DNA levels
have lower and the RNA levels are less
impacted so you see the RNA levels can
be higher than the DNA levels contrast
to that if you look on panel be in donor
samples that are happy positives or when
would assume that they're not on
treatment the values of DNA are on
average about one and a half logs higher
than the the RNA values so this is as
expected in a nice validation so we took
it a step further we wanted to
understand is the RNA produced from the
very start in an infection in the acute
phase and is it consistent to try and
understand if this is effectively the
RNA being released accidentally or is
there natural mechanism which the RNA
may be released into the plasma so we
studied plasmapheresis donors with acute
hepatitis B infection we had three of
them at our disposal two of them have
resolved the infection spontaneously and
one had gone Clark and you can see from
the right hand side the grass on the
right hand side two things one is that
the RNA is present very early on pretty
much from the get-go and that it is very
consistent to the DNA present a very
consistent levels and that as these
infections resolve obviously both
markers disappear and the RNA disappears
first and then the chronic infection
they track very nicely with the DNA and
they remain at about one and a half to
one point seven logs lower than the DNA
value also we're seeing a trend that the
x and core markers of this assays are
looking at the entire pre genomic RNA
and then the pre genomic RNA plus any
other foreign aids that may be present
it's very little there's really no
difference between the two so we're not
really seeing any evidence of any other
RNA molecules in the plasma other than
the entire pre genomic RNA this was some
interesting new findings based on this
research and kind of allowed us to
redraw this schematic which then shows
that the RNA is present from the acute
phase a very consistent level to the DNA
and then as expected the DNA drops when
you decide on what treatment is
initiated and that the RNA remains
constant and then over time will
decrease when somebody is on treated we
did some additional studies looking at
the correlation between the ex and the
core targets in our assay in chronic
patients and you can see here on the
left-hand side and time on a that the
correlation again is excellent and on
the right hand side that's in a blonde
almond that there again the correlation
is very good and that the discordance
are mostly at the low end of the dynamic
range but also that there's a slight
bias in favor of core about 0.2 log
units per mil and that's based on the
performance of the PCR reactions and not
really anything biological
in fact you've been doing quite a bit of
research with various institutions and
collaborators to try and understand the
potential clinical utility of the RNA
assay and this study was recently
presented in Vienna at the international
liver conference and it's collaboration
with King's College we looked at the
performance of the value of pre genomic
RNA on patients who are on nucleoside
analog treatment in this case we're
talking about tanaka vir and whether or
not they use e antigen yi antigen
positivity and loss is considered a
favorable clinical outcome so in this
study there were 28 Yonder positive
patients who received enough avea and
after immediate follow-up of 64 months
26 of them are 93% had become DNA
negative 17 or 61% had achieved the
antigen loss and one patient actually
achieved as antigen loss which would be
considered a functional cure there was
no significant difference in that
baseline but there were differences that
became apparent after about six months
of treatment where the patients who lost
e had a significant drop in their HPV
RNA relative to those who did not lose
easy as you can see in this slide about
those who did not lose
e had a median HB v RNA of 5 point 8 7
log versus 3.48 from those who who had
lossy you can see this down in panel see
here in this graphic also a drop of one
log units per mil of HPV RNA at six
months had a very good positive
predictive value of 71.4% so that was a
very interesting finding again this is a
relatively small end but this is a
powerful pointer as to a potential
clinical utility for this test and then
those who achieved as loss at a
significantly lower or na level at the
end of treatment at the last follow-up
you can see down here
in panel C the RNA levels are markedly
different between those who lost the and
those who did not so this would imply
that pre genomic RNA is a selective
marker for interrupted transcription of
CCC DNA whereas DNA reflects the
interruption of DNA replication by the
nucleoside unlocks
additional research again was conducted
with king's college and again presented
at the International River conference
earlier this year looked at the ability
to predict patients who may have an alt
flare following the withdrawal of new to
sadhana treatment so in this study 25
patients who had been suppressed for
three years were taken off treatment and
then followed for 52 weeks and we looked
at the ALP levels in these patients and
that's an indication of liver
inflammation and severe flares or severe
inflammation of the liver can require
somebody to be put back on treatment is
actually quite dangerous so it's
important will be useful to be able to
stratify patients and those who are at
risk of these severe flares maybe not a
good candidate candidate to withdraw
therapy
you can see in the bottom of this slide
the various kinetics so on the left hand
side here you can see the DNA drops very
rapidly in the first year for the vast
majority of patients becomes
undetectable within the first year and
with a small minority about three
patients it takes about two years to go
undetectable for their DNA and then on
the right hand side you can see that
that picture is very different when we
look at the RNA many patients become
undetectable after a year but several
become it takes three years or more to
become undetectable and actually a few
of them do not lose RNA at all if we
look at this trial and look at the first
of all what constitutes a flare verse
and stratifying it by minimal to no
flares which would be less than two of
the upper limit of normal loyalty about
nine patients fell into that category
mild would be between two and five of
the upper limit of normal and eleventh
patients fell into that category about
44% of this study and then severe flares
that were categorized as greater than
ten upper limit of normal there's about
five patients and twenty percent of the
study participants who fell into this
category and looking at this library
we're taking a look at the baseline
characteristics and you do see some
differences between the three different
groups that the baseline DNA was lower
among those who did not have a flare
versus those with a severe flare also
the correlative antigen assay I gave
results that were lower among those who
have no flare versus a flare and then
the RNA obviously also was significantly
lower in those who did not have a flare
versus those who did and seems to
increase between the mid and the severe
so these levels of markers either this
is very interesting data to stratify
patients based on risk at the at the
baseline but really in order to
effectively know when to treat somebody
you've got to look at the markers on
treatment or at the time when you're
considering taking them off treatment to
see if there's any indication as to the
safety of doing that and here we look at
the DNA
between those who have no Flair miles
flair and severe flair and as you can
see it's remarkably unremarkable there's
no difference between the three
populations in contrast are actually
similar to that if we look at the
surface antigen there's really no
significant difference between the three
and you can't tell them apart are
stratified patients who might be good
predictors are good candidates to stop
treatment you can test it out if we look
at the RNA four of the five patients who
have a severe flare still have
detectable and quantifiable
RNA at the time when treatment was
stopped so I think this is a indicate
that it might be a good predictor for
those patients who were candidates to
stay on treatment and not good
candidates to to withdrawal and you can
look
in rare cases especially about one to
two percent of patients with chronic Hep
B per year will lose surface antigen and
this is excuse me
of the infrequent but it's considered
the most favorable outcome it's
basically a functional cure so a loss of
that signage an undetectable DNA and
access the absence of ongoing liver
damage and in this study looking at
nineteen patients who were on long term
nucleoside analog treatment all of them
were non cirrhotic who achieved s loss
and we're a new casaya a lot of
treatment was withdrawn to patients
after a period of weeks had a relapse or
DNA became positive and they basically
would be considered to go back on
treatment and here we look at the HPV
DNA the pre genomic RNA vs antigen and
anti-hbs to see if there were any
predictors at the end of treatment to
see who or when treatment was at all to
see who might be good candidates for
this was role and who potentially should
be kept on treatment very interesting
how this broke apart because for DNA
again there's no real difference between
those two who relapsed versus the
population of seventeen and did not
surface antigen really didn't give us
much of a an indication either but again
the pre genomic RNA in the relapses was
still positive and quantifiable at the
time when the treatment was withdrawn
and also the antibody to surface antigen
in those who did not relapse was higher
than in those who did which would imply
that the they had a more robust immune
response that was keeping the virus in
check when the treatments eject the
antiviral treatment was withdrawn
so again this is showing the same data
but just with the table on the side here
that shows that the median or n/a value
was 0 we're in those who did not relapse
versus two logs roughly in the two
patients who did again relapse so this
could this would indicate that the RNA
si is a good predictor of those patients
who lose s who might be at risk of
relapse following the withdrawal of
Newcastle amyloid therapy
so changing directions slightly here
with these slides in subsequent signs
here we're looking at a different
therapy so it's not really standard of
care this is looking at some
experimental new therapies one
interesting compound is a silencing RNA
there's several of them in development
and in trials and will focus primarily
on some data that was generated with
this test using with the Arrowhead
compound so again looking at the life
cycle obviously the first thing that the
covalent closed circular DNA makes is
RNA and this the silencing RNA then
targets these pre genomic RNA and render
them useless and and impact the viral
life cycle very early on
this data is from the arc 520 trial this
compound is no longer in development
there's a revised and improved version
silencing RNA that's in clinical trials
right now and these this was put on a
backbone of antenna beer and leukocyte
analog treatment and a disturbed and
initial dose of art 520 was given and
you'll see a precipitous drop in both
DNA and RNA following the administration
of this silencing RNA here we're looking
at 3e antigen positive subject you can
see after a period of time the RNA
starts to rebound again the DNA does not
it continues to go down and that is
because these patients are can continue
on that backbone of Integra very mucus
out on therapists interrupts that
replication process so but later after a
period of weeks there were some other
additional doses of the silencing RNA
that were administered and again you can
see an additional drop in the DNA and
reflected also in a drop in the RNA in
these patients what was interesting in
among these three patients is that some
of them lost e antigen and that was
predicted by the drops in RNA as you can
see in the second patient down and also
in the third patient where the RNA drop
came back a little bit and then dropped
again in these two patients lost e
antigen which is again a very favorable
clinical outcome in these three patients
and this is a novel compound not not in
development but a good strategy for
potential curative therapies in
conclusion the measurement of hepatitis
B pre genomic RNA during the natural
history of happy and on treatment with
current or new agents could characterize
residual hepatitis B RNA and give us
some indication as to the
transcriptional activity of the convey
only close circular DNA decline of
hepatitis B RNA may present an important
goal for novel therapies with hepatitis
B pre genomic RNA decline potentially
being associated
today's verbal treatment endpoints we
showed in these previous slides the
measurement of FB RNA is a helpful
marker to predict sustained loss of s
antigen without HPV DNA reactivation
following the withdrawal of nucleoside
analog therapy
it was also useful in predicting
patients who may be at risk for severe
alt flares following the withdrawal of
therapy and also those who may benefit
from silencing RNAs and may lose s or
lose a antigen following these these
novel therapies and actually following
nucleoside analog treatment as well
additional large-scale trials are
ongoing that will hopefully help
elucidate the clinical utility of this
test further and we look forward to
reporting those results to you at a
future date the best
I'll bring the presentation who close
and open up for questions
Thank You Gavin for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
labeled ask a question and click on the
send button Gavin will answer as many
questions as time permits our first
question is viral load and HPSA G
classifications have real correlation
okay so I guess if we're if we're
talking about viral load from a HPV DNA
quantification versus surface antigen
the correlation is loose at best it's
not really a great correlation the if
we're talking about RNA it's the same
correlation is not always as good as one
might might hope there is some
correlation of course but not really
great there's a lot of debate about the
potential sources of surface antigen and
whether or not some of the detected
surface antigen is coming from
integrated DNA into the host genome so
that might explain why some of the
correlation is not as good as it
otherwise should be or could be
great thank you all right your next
question is
elevated intracellular PG RNA in
hpv-related hepatocellular carcinoma
tumor biopsies linked to patient
prognosis so I think these that's a good
question I think where the field is
looking at many biomarkers that may help
in the prognosis of people with with HCC
another we're involved in studies that
are looking at take PD RNA in plasma and
also correlating them to biopsy samples
so hopefully we can get some additional
information soon there are other HPV
molecular markers that may be better or
maybe other predictors of those who are
at higher risk of progressing to HCC
such as spliced variants so there's the
virus can sometimes splice and the
relative percentage of this splicing
going on may be indicative of those who
are at risk of progressing so lots of
activity in that area too
thank you has your team come across any
samples that had undetectable serum HPV
RNA with an elevated DNA load prior to
beginning na treatment that's an easy
that's a short answer would be no we've
not found any individuals who had high
HPV DNA with negative RNA we really do
find that trend of about one and a half
to two log difference it holds true
regardless of when we look as long as
they're not on therapy I would like to
once again thank Gavin for his
presentation I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor Abbott molecular for
today's educational webcast laberd's
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye
you